what i want to do now is just a series
of problems that really
make sure that we know what we're doing
with with with parallel lines and
triangles and all the rest and what we
have right here is a fairly classic
problem and what i want to do is i want
to figure out just given the information
here so obviously i have a triangle here
i have another triangle over here we
were given some of the angles inside of
these triangles given the information
over here i want to figure out what the
measure of this angle is right over
there i need to figure out what that
question mark is and so you might want
to give a go at it just knowing what you
know about the the sums of the measures
of the angles inside of a triangle and
maybe a little bit of what you know
about supplementary angles so you might
want to pause it and give it a try
yourself and because i'm about to give
you the solution
so the first thing you might say and
this is a general way to think about a
lot of these problems where they give
you some angles and you have to figure
out some other angles based on sum of
angles in a triangle equaling 180 or
this one doesn't have parallel lines on
it but you might see some with parallel
lines and and supplementary lines and
complementary lines is to just fill in
everything that you can figure out and
one way or another you'll probably be
able to figure out what this question
mark is so the first thing that kind of
pops out to me is we have one triangle
right over here
we have this triangle on the left
and on this triangle on the left we're
given two of the angles and if you have
two of the angles in a triangle you can
always figure out the third angle
because they're going to add up to 180
degrees so if you call that x we know
that x
plus 50
plus 64 is going to be equal to 180
degrees or we could say
x plus what is this 114
x plus 114 is equal to 180 degrees we
can subtract 114 from both sides of this
equation and we get x is equal to 180
minus 114 so 80 minus 14 80 minus 10
would be 70 minus another 4 is 66. so x
is 66 degrees
now if x is 66 degrees i think you might
find that there's another angle that's
not too hard to figure out so let me let
me write it like this so x
so x is equal to x
let me write x is equal to 66 degrees
is equal to 66 degrees well if we know
this angle right over here if we know
the measure of this angle is 66 degrees
we know that that angle is
is supplementary with this angle right
over here their outer sides form a
straight angle and they are adjacent so
if we call this angle right over here y
we know that y
plus x is going to be equal to
180 degrees and we know x is equal to 66
degrees so this is 66 and so we can
subtract 66 from both sides and we get y
is equal to these cancel out 180 minus
66 is 114 and that number might look a
little familiar to you notice this 114
was the exact same sum of these two
angles over here and that's actually a
general idea and i'll do it on the side
here just to prove it to you if i have
let's say that these two angles let's
say that the measure of that angle is a
the measure of that angle is b the
measure of this angle we know is going
to be 180 minus a minus b
that's this angle right over here and
then this angle which is considered to
be an exterior angle so in this example
y is an exterior angle in this example
that is our exterior angle that is going
to be supplementary to 180 minus a minus
b so this angle plus 180 minus a minus b
is going to be equal to 180. so if you
call this angle y
you would have y
plus
minus a
minus b is equal to
180. you could subtract 180 from both
sides you can add a plus b to both sides
so plus a plus b
plus a plus b running out of space on
the right hand side and then you're left
with
these cancel out on the left hand side
you're left with y on the right hand
side is equal to a plus b so this is
just a general property you can you can
just reason it through yourself just
with the sum of the measures of inside
of an of the angles inside of a triangle
add up to 180 degrees and then you have
a supplementary angles right over here
or you can just say look if i have the
exterior angles right over here it's
equal it's equal to the sum of the
remote interior angles that's just a
little terminology you'd see there so y
is equal to a plus b 114 degrees we've
already shown to ourselves is equal to
64 plus 50 degrees
but anyway regardless of how we do it if
we just reason it out step by step or if
we just knew this property from the get
go if we know that y is equal to 114
degrees and i like to reason it out
every time just to make sure i'm not
jumping to conclusions so if y is 114
degrees now we know this angle we know
we were given this angle at the
beginning now we just have to figure out
this third angle in this in this
triangle so if we call this z
if we call this question mark is equal
to z we know that z plus 114 we know
that z plus 114 plus 31 is equal to 180
degrees the the sums of the measures of
the angle inside of a triangle add up to
180 degrees that's the only property
we're using in this step so we get z
plus what is this 145
145 is equal to 180 did i do that right
if i we have
we have a 15 and then a 30 yep 145 is
equal to 180 subtract 145 from both
sides of this equation and we are left
with
z is equal to
80 minus 45 is equal to 35 so z is equal
to 35 degrees and we are done